pense une question tintin at il oui ou
non ces journées à saint nazaire
oui bien évidemment bien évidemment
puisque ça se fait d'ailleurs dans
l'album les sept boules de cristal pour
la ville où nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui c'est un événement assez
marquant le passage de tintin pour que
la ville de saint nazaire et lui
consacre une exposition exposition
visité par deux tintinophiles claude
crespo et jean picard
entre cargo et méthaniers entre odeurs
diodes et vapeurs de goudron saint
nazaire sous les cris des mouettes
semblent n'avoir guère changé depuis ces
bulles sorti de l'imagination des rejets
aujourd'hui en pleine ville elles sont
devenues vignette pour perpétuer le
séjour de tintin dans ce port de
l'atlantique
l'enquêté menée par ce journaliste
tintinophiles il adore tout ce qui
touche à ce héros est un sinologue
intarissable sur le sujet sans odeur et
est une des rares villes figurait dans
les albums de tintin en particulier
villes françaises et ça ne sert figure
dans les sept boules de cristal r j'ai
fait venir tata et le capitaine haddock
à saint nazaire
parce qu'ils sont sur la trace du
service heures du professeur tournesol
dont la voiture était signalé dans les
environs de saint nazaire par la police
de saint nazaire
la raison pour laquelle il a choisi
saint nazaire c'est que saint nazaire
étaient têtes de ligne de la compagnie
générale transatlantique pour l'amérique
centrale et l'amérique du sud
une exposition renforcée cet hommage
son thème tintin haddock et les bateaux
ou l'histoire d'une amitié tout au long
de leur aventure maritime
jean-claude chemin qui en est
l'instigateur a su recréer un trois
dimensions l'univers du reporter belge
au point d'aller s'enquérir auprès d'un
spécialiste animateur sur le sous-marin
l'espadon j'ai la véracité d'un autre
insubmersible celui du professeur
tournesol second ça c'est que hergé
s'est inspiré de photos de sous marins
de poche de la guerre mondiale et de
documents de sous marins de poche d'un
amateur américain
point d'orgue de l'exposition qui chacun
le sait concerne tout le monde de 7 à 77
ans la galerie des jurons avec parfois
la matérialisation de certains d'entre
eux on aura reconnu le célébrissime où
la gauche voilà un scolopendre bref 253
jurons à déguster et la liste n'est pas
exhaustive
jean claude semin a même rencontré un
marin que n'aurait pas renié le
capitaine haddock
citer 1 - macklowe que j'ai connu à
l'époque à la 37 sur le carry marie
c'est qu'on est vieux cargo et sita bon
match les bretons franche coquet en lui
son jurons suprême s'était tremblement
de wagons bon dieu de vieilles marina
colbert alors quand il sortait sans
c'était fabuleux
tintin et le capitaine haddock ont jeté
l'ancré à saint nazaire
jusqu'au 22 novembre
patrick et moi avons eu le temps de
noter tremblement de wagons de bon dieu
de vieilles marina colbert vous allez
vous en servir cet après midi pour les
sprints n'ont peut-être pas alors